solve this system and once again we have
three equations with three unknowns so
this is essentially trying to figure out
where three different planes would
intersect in three dimensions and to do
this if we want to do it by elimination
if we want to be able to eliminate
variables it looks like well it looks
like we have a negative Z here we have a
plus 2z we have a 5z over here if we
were to scale up this third equation by
positive two then you would have a
negative 2z here and it would cancel out
with this 2z there and then if you were
to scale it up by five you'd have a
negative 5z here and then that could
cancel out with that 5z over there so
let's try to cancel out let's try to
eliminate the Z's first so let me start
with this equation up here I'll just
rewrite it so we have I'll draw an arrow
over here we have x + 2 y + 5 Z is equal
to negative 17 and then to cancel out or
to eliminate the Z's I'll multiply this
equation here times 5 so I'm going to
multiply this equation times 5 so we
have to multiply both sides by 5 so 3x
times 5 is 15 X Y times 5 is plus 5y and
then negative Z times 5 is negative 5 Z
that's the whole point while we're
multiplying it by 5 is equal to 3 times
5 which is equal to 15 and so if we add
these two equations we get x + 15 X is
16 X 2y + 5 y is 7 y + 5 z minus 5z or
plus negative 5 z those are going to
cancel out and that is going to be equal
to negative 17 plus 15 is negative 2 so
we were able to use the constraints in
that equation in that equation and now
we have an equation in just x + y so
let's try to do the same thing let's try
to eliminate the Z's
but now use this equation and this
equation so this equation let me just
rewrite it over here we have 2x minus 3y
plus 2z is equal to negative 16 i just
rewrote it and now so that this 2z gets
eliminated let's multiply this equation
times 2 so let's multiply it times 2 so
a negative 2z here to eliminate with the
positive 2z so 2 times 3x is 6x 2 times
y is plus 2y and then 2 times negative z
is negative 2 z is equal to 2 times 3 is
equal to 6 and now we can add these two
equations 2x + 6 X is 8x negative 3y
plus 2y is negative Y and then these two
guys get cancelled out and then that is
equal to negative 16 plus 6 is negative
is negative 10 so now we have two
equations with two unknowns we've
eliminated the Z's and let's see if we
want to eliminate again we have a
negative Y over here we have a positive
7y well we could eliminate the Y's if we
multiply this times 7 and add the two
equation so let's do that so let's
multiply this times 7 7 times 8 is 56 7
times 8 is so it's 56 X minus 7y minus
7y is equal to 7 times negative 10 is
equal to negative is equal to negative
70 and now we can add these two
equations I'm now trying to eliminate
the Y's so we have 16x + 56 X that is 72
X so we have 72 X these guys eliminate
equal to negative 72 equal to negative
72 negative 2 plus negative 70 divided
both sides by 72 and we get X is equal
to negative 1 and now we just have to
substitute back to figure out what y&z
are equal to so let's we could go back
to this equation right over here so we
have 8x minus y is equal to negative 10
if X is equal to negative 1 that means 8
times negative 1 or negative 8 minus y
is equal to negative 10 we can add 8 to
both sides and so we have negative Y is
equal to negative 2 or multiplying both
sides by negative 1 Y is equal
to to let me square that off so X is
equal to negative one y is equal to two
we now just have to worry about Z and we
can go back to any of these up here so
let's just use I'll just use this last
one the numbers seem lower so if I we
substitute back into this last equation
right over here we have 3 times X which
is 3 times negative 1 plus y which is 2
minus Z is equal to 3 so it's negative 3
plus 2 minus Z is equal to 3 and this is
negative 1 minus Z is equal to 3 and
then add 1 to both sides add 1 to both
sides we get these cancel out negative Z
is equal to 4 multiplying both sides by
negative 1 you get Z is equal to
negative 4 so we're done let's verify
that these solutions or this solution of
X negative 1 y is equal to 2 Z is equal
to negative 4 actually satisfies all
three of these constraints so let's
substitute into this first one so you
have X plus 2y plus 5z so that is X is
negative 1 plus 2 times y so plus 4 plus
5z so minus 20 has to be equal to
negative 17 and this is negative this
right here is positive 3 minus 20 is
indeed equal to negative 17 so it
satisfies the first constraint let's
look at the second one 2 times X 2 times
negative 1 that's negative 2 minus 3
times y that's minus 6 3 times 2 is 6
minus 6 plus 2 times Z Z is negative 4
so that's 2 times negative 4 is negative
8 that needs to equal negative 16
negative 2 minus negative 8 is sorry 2
negative 2 minus negative 6 is negative
8 subtract another 8 you get negative 16
so it meets the second constraint and
then finally let's look at the last
constraint we have 3 times X 3 times X
so negative 3 plus y so plus 2 minus Z
so minus negative 4 is the same thing as
plus 4 that needs to be equal to 3
so negative three plus two is negative
one plus four is indeed equal to three
so we found our the point of
intersection in three dimensions of
these three of these three planes X is
negative one Z is negative four Y is two
and we were able to verify that it does
indeed meet all of the constraints